zona are the the gentle path
no no because that's a full-on sex one
yeah no but we had
mostly people were that were in it it
was mostly for trauma no it was trauma
but they were there were sex addicts
yeah
i mean there was uh they're addicts
that whole thing the red yellow i had to
write that chart as well right yeah
circle plan right right
and is that curtailed to each person
like what that looks like okay
for sure so like so some people will
have like
you know if if i act out with
pornography that's relapse other
people you know not so much like for me
that would be
the the yellow light behavior even
though i just don't [ __ ] with god
but for me it was like going to strip
clubs was not
in the thing and then my therapist my
counselor was like
no that should be in the red i go why
because he goes he was telling me that
because by you partaking in that right
these women
not all but most right or some
right also are people who are victims of
trauma
right and it's just you're you're you're
feeding into that you know i mean
cycle right and so i remember putting
that
into that porn was in that you know and
um the banana massage parlor
what's the bananas yeah they're rubbing
toenails which one's that one
which one's it what's the address or
whatever
is there one called the banana massager
[Laughter]
you know it's funny what the massage
joints before i met you
my friend and i saying that yeah
he's like we should just do it right now
i've never done it before so we went to
a place
and like a place that he normally goes
to and there was a gate
and i had a doc he had to bring it you
know you had to ring up
do a buzzer and then hello and the woman
looked through the window and she goes
no she looked at me and she goes no then
we went to another place
same thing happened no but did she say
yes
yes because he had been to both places
so i thought
i look like a narc do i look like a narc
i wonder because it's such a uh
predominantly
asian thing like massage parlors yeah
i don't know if that's yeah i don't know
you look like my
brother all right maybe it's the
um the asian model minority myth they
don't want to see you go down like that
maybe they're they're okay seeing the
white man go down but not not her
brother
how hard i think that could be it could
be or maybe they
they uh they don't want to be
they don't want you to see them doing
that oh shame shame yeah
how old how horrifying would it be if
you see this right someone open up a
curtain
and you go mom it was your mom
that would be a nightmare worst right
because then i would have to get in
there and just
try to fix it
yeah congratulations to us man
congratulations to us isn't it great
like to not have like you know like all
of the
the attendant [ __ ] stress
of like and and dude with me i was just
like one of these
[ __ ] jerks where you know like like
i'm super into the girl and then like i
hook up with him and
i'm not into him anymore yeah you know
like that whole it was
it was just like sociopathic this
[ __ ] pattern of like
you know pouring on the charm this like
like you know and really feeling like
infatuated
with with the woman and pouring on the
roping around it was just like the
you know the equivalent of just being
like
misleading and exploitative and then
neglectful and then abandoning you know
like
it was just [ __ ] up man and and and
the shame that i would have like when
you know
when i went through that cycle it's like
oh you know i hear i burned someone you
know
yeah i just burned someone with the
ghost routine like
i would feel my self-esteem was
just [ __ ] non-existent yeah and i
think that whenever
we're in a position where we are feeling
victimized
or resentful it's the really helpful
thing to be able to put yourself
in the shoes of the person towards your
feeling resentful
yeah hey guys we're gonna take a quick
break to show